- We're almost at the end of the show
but I can't close out before
sharing one last story
to bring you joy and laughter.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
Let's be honest, no one
likes a wedding crasher,
unless you're the one crashing it.
That's just part of what is
amazing about this TikTok post.
Just look.
- [Angie] A bear showed
up at my cousin's wedding.
(metal clangs)
(wedding guests murmur)
(audience cheers)
- What the hell?
They're acting like a dog
(audience laughs)
just came.
Like, I know black bears don't
attack you like grizzlies,
but, like, it's not a dog
(audience laughs)
and all these people are just
like, "Yeah, I'm just eating my," what?
We have the woman who captured that moment
joining us now say "hi"
to Angie who watches
on NBC7 San Diego at 2:00pm.
(audience cheers)
So, Angie, first of all, rad
choice of color for your hair.
Secondly, no one seemed
phased by an actual bear
just hanging out at the wedding.
Is that normal at weddings you go to?
- Well, hi, Kelly.
So yeah, this happened
in my cousin's wedding
down in Mexico, in a national
park, called Chipinque.
There was a hotel there, it's beautiful.
There's a forest, there's mountains,
and the staff told us to be in the lookout
for some bears and more
animals, mostly the black bear.
So over there, just at the
reception, you know, normal,
we were eating some
appetizers when these bear
just crashes the wedding.
And, you know, we were all very mesmerized
and very surprised about this,
but the staff, who very quickly
and told us not to move,
they were banging chairs on the floor
so it would make a sound, so
the bear will, like, you know,
get scared and go away.
But, like, the funniest
part is, like, you know,
my family took it a
little bit too literally
when they told us, like,
"Oh, just pretend like
it's nothing there."
So, yeah, the staff
made us feel very safe.
- You are
(audience claps)
from a family of warriors
is all I'm saying, Angie.
That was an awesome video, I loved it.
Thank you for sharing.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(bell dings)
- [Angie] Thank you so much.
- Look at the paws, it's amazing.
He's, like, "Oh, can I have this steak?"
(Kelly chuckles)
He's like.
That's not all, though.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson
Show" thinks that your video
is unbelievably awesome as we do,
so they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars
just 'cause it's awesome.
(audience cheers)
(Kelly claps)
- Thank you, so much.
- [Kelly] Have fun with that money.